Independence Day resurgence is actually
a movie do you know how long I've been
hearing about Independence Day - I was
alive for when this movie was huge it
was everything that my school talked
about Independence Day was a VHS tape
staple and all of my friends collections
it was just like the movie of my
childhood it was sort of like the Star
Wars of the 90s and then you watch it a
few more times and you're like oh this
is actually really corny but it's still
fun you know it has like this vibe of
charisma and energy and fun so naturally
I was excited to see Independence Day
resurgence which is directed once again
by roland emmerich and stars Jeff
Goldblum liam hemsworth not Will Smith
not Mae Whitman as well as Bill Pullman
we're going to live on today we
celebrate our Independence Day hello
boys I'm back so what happens in this
movie well the aliens come back and they
want to destroy earth that's it
so basically Independence Day except
they came back differences this time
around is that Earth has now integrated
alien technology with their own man-made
technology so they have more stuff at
their disposal more intense weaponry
more advanced technology because they
have learned from what happened 20 years
ago so how is this movie well it's a big
loud CGI fest with tons of cheesy
cornball dialogue moments where military
personnel are all grouped in a circle
discussing the fate of the earth and
Jeff Goldblum going uh well there it is
in other words it's pretty much exactly
like the first one in almost every way
except for a few things two very
important things two things that I
mentioned the first film had charisma
and energy Independence Day resurgence
has none of this this movie is mindless
fun if you go into Independence Day
resurgence expecting that you're going
to get it just like Independence Day one
and that's what I want out of an
Independence Day movie I want mindless
fun I want to see alien ships blow up
and crazy random shit and Jeff Goldblum
being awesome
and I got that but what I didn't get was
a sense of urgency there's no charisma
Will Smith's absence is actually very
sorely felt in this movie because he has
a lot of charisma the replacement for
him is his son who is pretty bad and
very bland
I mean dull really dull and he has
dialogue to work with that could be more
exciting but he does nothing with it
Liam Hemsworth is Liam Hemsworth he
basically plays the same type of
character he plays in every movie he's
likable he tries to have some fun with
this movie I'll give you one guess
what's the best part of this movie say
it with me five four three two one Jeff
Goldblum he's a well trained actor he's
by far the best part of this movie his
character is still entertaining he has
some good one-liners he's fun he
actually feels like he's having a good
time everyone else just kind of feels
like they're in this movie because it's
Independence Day so you know we kind of
have to do it let's talk about Michael
Monroe an actress I really like I liked
her a lot and it follows and the guest
she plays the president's daughter who
an independence day was played by the
very young Mae Whitman who's grown up to
be a very talented actress and I have no
idea why they didn't cast her in this
movie it makes no sense to me why they
replaced her with someone else maybe
there's some behind-the-scenes reason
that I don't know about but I'm just
sitting here hoping that it's not
because she's not a fucking Sports
Illustrated supermodel if that's the
reason I'm fucking pissed because Mae
Whitman is super talented and she should
have been in this movie and that's my
rant on the president's daughter
character good things about this movie
you can watch it it has moments of
escapism and fun the CG is sometimes
impressive but it does suffer from a lot
of shit on the screen at once syndrome
Rick McCallum the producer of Episode
one the Phantom Menace would refer to it
as so dense one of the biggest problems
with this movie though is a humongous
overabundance of characters there are
times where I'm watching this movie and
it just keeps going and going and you're
thinking okay we're in the movie now
right oh my god we're still being
introduced to more side characters why
are you even in this movie car filled
with children
brent Spiner is back in this film and
he has too much screen time he's funny
at times but he's given way too much
stuff to do in this movie for the type
of character he is there's also a guy
named Floyd who's sort of the most
annoying person in this movie who also
just so happens to be one of the writers
he's given a lot to do he's supposed to
be like the roland emmerich guy you know
what I mean he's the guy who runs around
saying shit that's supposed to be funny
who was that guy in Independence Day
how'd a neg oh my god had to call my
mother oh it's a call my lawyer
oh forget my lawyer David oh my god I
had an Independence Day resurgence the
Floyd character is now the David guy and
he's in this movie way too much this
movie also has the most absurd on the
nose set up for Independence Day 3 when
it ended my mouth actually dropped I was
just like no fucking way look Jeff
Goldblum is fun to watch in this movie I
love seeing his character back I love
seeing him in movies like this put him
in Jurassic world to please the movie
has some fun sequences and I'm not just
blinded by nostalgia I recognized the
first independence day is a very cheesy
movie it's a very mindless fun movie but
what that movie had was energy and a
sense of urgency and charisma this movie
doesn't have that sense of stakes it
doesn't have that sense of urgency or
that excitement it just sort of is there
I'm going to give Independence Day
resurgence a see guys thank you so much
as always for watching a couple years
ago on July 4th I actually reviewed the
very first Independence Day with my
buddy the Flik pic there's going to be
annotation for that at the end of this
video if you want to check out my
original review of Independence Day also
I want to let you know that I'm
restarting my promotion with
crunchyroll.com these guys have been
amazing in the past and I'm super
excited that I get to work with them
again if you go to crunchyroll.com slash
Chris Stockman you can try their premium
service for free for 30 days this is
basically the best anime streaming
service on earth and I am a huge fan of
anime as you know they have so much
stuff in fact sometimes an hour after it
premieres in Japan you get to watch it
in America
which is unprecedented for anime fans
and so cool and I'm so excited to get to
work with them again their top series
for the spring are easy row starting
life in another world twin star
exorcists kids Naver and bungo stray
dogs I'm a huge anime fan I love
supporting it I love that services like
crunchyroll exist so please visit
crunchyroll.com slash Chris Stockman you
can try their premium service for 30
days for free and you can stream it
across just about any device that you
own it's awesome guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes